shortly but what I would point out is
that clearly all organizations are
facing Rising costs that is in part why
we have acted so swiftly and even today
uh we'll be putting through legislation
to help with the business and cost of
living Richard Thompson thank you Mr
Speaker
the Prime Minister has been in office
for six weeks but notoriously even with
the rigors of the budget is yet to find
time to call the first minister of
Scotland or the first minister of Wales
there's a leader of the House think that
the Prime Minister will remain in office
long enough to be able to do so
I know the Prime Minister takes her
responsibilities
prime minister is now entering the
chamber and sitting down behind Penny
mordant constructively with the other
administrations and she will always do
that
just in matters thank you Mr Speaker I'm
sure the markets will be reassure to see
the prime ministers not hiding under a
desk but it's here in the house today
she's still got till 10 o'clock tonight
to answer questions that have been asked
if she wants to reassure the markets and
create some stability but I've got
another question for the leader of the
house I've been drawn in prime
minister's questions on Wednesday can
she guarantee that the current prime
minister will be answering them
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker throwing your
Chancellor under the bus in order to
save your skin is not a tough decision
tough decisions are when you make them
and then come along show True leadership
and ask people to come with you by
inspiring them this prime minister has
done none of that so why should we
follow her when she's shown no
leadership whatsoever but is hidden away
through the house I think that if you
spoke to any member of the Ukrainian
Parliament they would tell you that our
prime minister
thank you Mr Speaker
urgent business we are told by the
leader prevented the Prime Minister for
coming to the house what on Earth could
have been more urgent than coming to
atone for the economic chaos that she
has wrought on pension holders and
mortgage pairs across these islands and
especially in Scotland with a party
officer enjoying no mandate whatsoever
the Prime Minister thanked her former
Chancellor for the excellent work that
he had done can the leader of the House
explain or maybe now the prime
minister's turned up she can can the
leader house explain fact for what
The Honorable gentleman will know that
the Prime Minister has prime minister's
questions uh every single week he can
put questions to her there
um there was very good reason as I have
repeatedly explained to the house why
she could be here you'll notice that she
is present here now and I will start
listening to The Honorable Gentleman on
Democratic mandates when he honors the
results of the Scottish referendum
thank you very Mr speaker thank the
leader of the house for her answers but
I'm not in the business of Point scoring
does the leader of the house not agree
that the face behind the budget is much
less important than what the budget
outlines is there confidence that the
chancellor can help business help people
stay and work ensure that funding is
available for the NHS and government
departments cannot take further
austerity so all the United Kingdom of
Great Britain and Northern Ireland can
truly be better together
well The Honorable gentleman is held in
great affection by all members of this
house and is often the finale at such
uqs because he is full of common sense
and I think that what he says is
absolutely right and I hope now we will
be able to hear from the chancellor very
shortly
[Applause]
[Music]
is it
relevant to the questions
[Applause]
expressions
order if it's relevant to this I would
say at the point of order Chris Brown
I'm grateful Mr Speaker on a point of
order you know that for the last hour
we've been listening to questions about
which were meant to be directed to the
Prime Minister the leader of the House
said repeatedly that there were reasons
that the Prime Minister could couldn't
be here if there were legitimate Reasons
I'm sure every single member of this
house would want
to hear them now that the Prime Minister
has arrived would this not be a perfect
opportunity for her to be able to
explain why she was not able to do it
just to say let's just put this to bed
it's not for me it's for the government
to put forward the ministers to respond
to Urgent questions once granted and
it's not a matter for the church there
are members put the point on the record
and I know that the prime minister is
now in her place but we know come before
I call the chancellor to make his stick
I expect better I want you to be silent
while I read this so this is very
important before I call the chancellor
to make a statement of life
yes and I think so it's a few times
today and that's the third apology I
don't want anymore
before I call the chancellor to make
history I'd like to point out that
British sign language interpretation of
proceedings is available to watch on
Parliament live TV so I had no call the
chancellor of the exchequer
[Applause]
thank you
Mr Speaker
the central responsibility of any
government is to do what is necessary
for economic stability
behind the decisions we take and the
issues on which we vote
are jobs families depend on mortgages
that have to be paid savings for
pensioners and businesses investing for
the future
we are a country that funds our promises
and pays our debts and when that is
questioned as it has been this
government will take the difficult
decisions necessary to ensure there is
trust and confidence in our national
finances
that means decisions of eye-watering
difficulty
but I give the house and the public this
assurance
every single one of those decisions
where the reductions in spending or
increases in tax will be shaped through
core compassionate conservative values
[Music]
vulnerable
that is why I pay tribute to my
predecessors
for the energy price guarantee
furlough scheme and indeed for earlier
decisions to protect the NHS budget in a
period when other budgets were being cut
but Mr Speaker I want to be completely
Frank about the scale of the economic
challenge we face
we have had short-term difficulties
we have had short-term difficulties
caused by the lack of an obr forecast
alongside the mini budget
missionary and interest pressures around
the world Russia's unforgivable invasion
of Ukraine has caused energy and food
prices to spike we cannot control what
is happening in the rest of the world
but when the interest of economic
stability means the government needs to
change course we will do so and that is
what I've come to the house to announce
today
in my first few days in the job I've
held extensive discussions with the
Prime Minister cabinet colleagues the
governor of the bank of England the obr
the head of the debt management office
treasury officials and many others
the conclusion I've drawn from those
conversations is that we need to do more
more quickly to give certainty to the
markets about our fiscal plans and show
through action and not just words that
the United Kingdom can and always will
pay our way in the world
we've therefore decided to make further
changes to the mini budget immediately
rather than waiting until the
medium-term fiscal plan in two weeks
time in order to reduce unhelpful
speculation about those plans
Mr Speaker I'm very grateful for your
agreement
on the need to give the markets an early
brief summary this morning but I welcome
the opportunity to give this house
details of those decisions now
we've decided on the following changes
to support confidence and stability
firstly the Prime Minister and I agreed
yesterday to reverse almost all the tax
measures announced in the growth plan
three weeks ago that have not been
legislated for in Parliament so we will
continue with the abolition of the
Health and Social care Levy changes to
stamp Duty the increase in the annual
investment allowance to a million pounds
and The Wider reforms to investment
taxes but we will no longer be
proceeding with the cuts to Dividend tax
rates saving around a billion pounds a
year the reversal of the off payroll
working reforms introduced in 2017 and
2021 saving around 2 billion pounds a
year the new vat-free shopping scheme
for non-uk visitors saving a further two
billion pounds a year or the freeze on
alcohol Duty rates saving around 600
million pounds a year
I will provide further details on how
those rates will be upgraded just let's
just Swap this telephone
I would prefer to provide further
details on how alcohol Duty rates will
be upgraded shortly
second the government is currently
committed to cutting the basic rate of
income tax to 19 in April of 2023 it is
a deeply held conservative value a value
that I share that people should keep
more of the money they earn which is why
we have continued with the abolition of
the Health and Social care level
but at a time when markets are asking
serious questions about our commitment
to sound public finances we cannot
afford a permanent discretionary
increase in borrowing worth 6 billion
pounds a year so I've decided that the
basic rate of income tax will remain at
20 percent and it will do so
indefinitely until economic
circumstances allow for it to be cut
taken together with the decision not to
cut corporation tax and restoring the
top rate of income tax the measures I've
announced today will raise around 32
billion pounds every year
the third step I'm taking today Mr
Speaker is to review the energy price
guarantee
that was the biggest single expense in
the growth plan and one of the most
generous schemes in the world it's a
landmark policy for which I pay tribute
to my predecessor my right honorable
friend from spellthore and we'll support
millions of people through a difficult
winter reducing inflation by up to five
percent so I confirm today that the
support we are providing between now and
April next year will not change
but beyond next April the Prime Minister
and I have reluctantly agreed it would
not be responsible to continue exposing
the public finances to unlimited
volatility in international gas prices
so I'm announcing today a treasury-led
review into how we support energy bills
Beyond April next year the reviews
objective is to design a new approach
that will cost a taxpayer significantly
less than planned whilst ensuring enough
support for those in need
any support for businesses will be
targeted to those most affected and a
new approach will better incentivize
Energy Efficiency
there remain I'm afraid many difficult
decisions to be announced in the medium
term fiscal plan on October the 31st
when I confirm that we will publish a
credible transparent fully costed plan
to get debt falling as a share of the
economy over the medium term based on
the judgment and economic forecasts of
the independent office for Budget
responsibility I'd like to thank the obr
who's director Richard Hughes I met this
morning and the bank of England whose
Governor Andrew Bailey I've now met
twice I fully support the vital
independent roles both institutions play
which give markets the public and the
world confidence that our economic plans
are credible
and rightly hold us to account for
delivering them but I also want more
independent expert advice as I start my
journey as Chancellor so I'm announcing
today the formation of a new economic
advisory Council to do just that this
Council will advise the government on
economic policy
with four names announced today Rupert
Harrison former Chief of Staff to the
chance of the exchequer Gertz Jan
vlieger from element capital sushil
wadwani of wadwani asset management and
Karen ward of JP Morgan
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
we remain completely committed to our
mission to go for growth but growth
requires confidence and stability which
is why we are taking many difficult
decisions starting today
but whilst we do need realism about the
challenges ahead we must never fall into
the Trap of pessimism despite all the
adversity and challenge we Face there is
enormous potential in this country with
some of the most talented people three
of the world's top 10 universities the
most tech unicorns in Europe one of the
world's great Financial Centers
incredible strengths in the creative
Industries in science research
engineering manufacturing and Innovation
and all that gives me genuine optimism
about our long-term prospects for growth
but
but to achieve that
Now to create the stability on which
future Generations can build the reason
the United Kingdom has always succeeded
is because at big and difficult moments
we have taken tough decisions in the
long-term interests of the country and
in a way that is consistent with
compassionate conservative values that
is what we will do now and I commend the
statement of the house
I know Cole
the shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves
thank you Mr Speaker I as I regulate
healing the new Chancellor for his place
the fourth in four months of chaos and
Fiasco as this conservative government
spirals down the political plug hole but
the damage has been done this is a Tory
crisis made in Downing Street but
ordinary working people are paying the
price all that is left after these
humiliating u-turns are higher mortgages
for working people and higher bonuses
for bankers and their climbed down on
energy support begs the question yet
again why won't they extend the windfall
tax on energy producers to help foot the
bill
now it is good to finally see the prime
minister in her place and not as the
leader of the house had to assure us
earlier under a desk
Mr Speaker what is she left with no
Authority no no credibility no plan for
growth and it is clear to see the people
who cause the chaos cannot be the people
to fix the chaos they are out of ideas
out of touch and out of time
now the Prime Minister should have spoke
to the house today
but we know that she cannot do that with
a shred of credibility given that the
survival of this government now depends
on smashing to Smithereens everything
that she stands for and now she's
attempting to reverse everything that
she campaigned on it is not just
impossible it is absurd the prime
minister is barely in office and she is
certainly not in power
only five days ago the Prime Minister
said our prime minister's questions that
there would be and I quote absolutely no
public spending reductions but after
what we have heard from the chancellor
today every single public service is
again at risk from the conservatives
from our NHS nurses to our schools to
our servicemen and women with the
country paying the price for their
incompetence
the Prime Minister said that she had an
energy package for two years now that's
been withdrawn on the very day it is
supposed to be legislated for the Prime
Minister insisted that her conservative
mini budget would lead the country to
the promised land instead it has led to
the highest mortgages in 15 years and
emergency interventions by the bank of
England to protect pensions and then on
Friday the unedifying spectacle of the
chancellor being dragged back from the
IMF before he could do any more damage
to our economy
so she has turned to a new chancellor
who finished eighth out of eight in the
Tory leadership contest winning just 18
votes from MPS the Tories have run out
of credibility and now they are running
out of chancellors
the latest office holder has been in the
cabinet for nine of the last 12 years at
the center of a government responsible
for low growth and weakened public
services and him responsible for helping
run the NHS into the grounds
he was a big part of austerity season
one and now he says the Cure is
austerity season two and what Mr Speaker
was the Chancellor's Flagship policy in
his own short-lived leadership contest
to reduce corporation tax in a totally
unfunded manner not from 25 to 19 the
right honorable gentleman called for it
to be lowered to 15 with not a single
explanation of how it was to be paid for
the truth is had he won the contest and
implemented these policies we would be
in an even worse place than we are now
there is no mandate there is no
Authority for any of this
[Applause]
the conservatives have put a lasting
premium on people's mortgages uncosted
borrowing has sent interest rates
spiraling millions of people's mortgage
deals will be coming to an end in the
next three months leaving many families
forking out 500 pounds or more a month
you will be paying a Tory mortgage
premium for years to come so how does
the chancellor think Ordinary People can
possibly afford any more of this
conservative government we've heard no
answers today now the chancellor has
said that growth requires confidence and
stability
I I agree but where does he think the
lack of confidence and the lack of
stability has come from it didn't come
from the sky Mr Speaker it came from the
mini budget three weeks ago
and what does it say about our country
that we are watching borrowing costs
hour by hour
it's not the sign of a strong G7 economy
it is the exact opposite businesses are
now saying that things are so unstable
that they are pausing investment here in
Britain the former deputy governor of
the bank of England Charles Bean has
outlined the extraordinary damage that
the conservatives have done to our
standing in his words we've moved from
looking not too dissimilar from the U.S
or Germany to looking more like Italy
and Greece what a mess and where is the
officer budget responsibility forecast
has this government learned nothing does
the chancellor really expect the country
to take everything from him at face
value last week the business secretary
was busy undermining the office for
Budget responsibility today we have
received another massive fiscal
statement with no forecast what has this
government's got to hide they should
publish the numbers so that we know the
true state of the public finances after
40 days of this prime minister and after
12 years of conservative governments
now today the chancellor has scaled back
help with energy bills for families and
pensioners it begs the question yet
again why won't they bring in a proper
windfall tax on energy producers to help
put the bills for consumers and when
will the current Chancellor publish in
full the government's estimates of
windfall profits of the energy Giants
over the next two years now no one was
talking about spending cuts until the
Tories crashed the economy with their
many budgets so I asked the chancellor
why should the British people pay the
economic price for the tourist mistakes
and what spending parts does the
government plan to make
we believe that the government must
honor its commitments to Upright
benefits and pensions in line with
inflation will the chancellor make it
clear today that that is what he intends
to do
and what a contrast that cuts to
benefits are still on the table but the
one thing that Chancellor couldn't bring
himself to reverse today was lifting the
cap on Bankers bonuses why is this the
last policy standing in this disastrous
mini budget and let me come to
credibility does the chancellor accept
that once credibility and Trust have
been destroyed it cannot be simply
regained by a series of zigzagging
chaotic u-turns will he and the Prime
Minister apologize for the costs and
auxilities laid on families can he admit
once and for all that the market turmoil
we are in was directly caused by the
disastrous decisions of his predecessor
and of the Prime Minister can he
guarantee that the bank of England won't
have to intervene again to save the
government and what guarantee can he
give to people about their pensions
about their mortgages and their
household bills
the chancellor said today that
everything is now on the table
but is that really the case we know that
abolishing the non-dome tax status will
raise three billion pounds a year yet
there was no mention of that today how
can it be right that some of the richest
individuals in society allowed to buy
their way out of paying tax that should
be paid here in Britain this would not
be an eye-wateringly difficult decision
Mr Speaker so why doesn't the government
just do it
[Applause]
there is lasting damage which these
policy u-turns won't change
they've set fire to everything now they
insist it is all fine
the truth is Mr Speaker
an arsonist is still an arsonist even if
he runs back into a burning building
with a bucket of water because they
can't be trusted the Tories are Clinging
On for themselves regardless of the cost
to the country trickle-down economics
will always fail what drives forward our
economy are the talents and efforts of
millions of working people and thousands
of ordinary businesses the government's
economic credibility has been destroyed
they have harmed our Economic
Institutions people are paying higher
mortgages the same set of people doing
u-turns isn't going to fix it the only
way to change this is a real change in
governments
foreign
I Thank The Honorable lady for her
questions and I'm sorry that given the
speed at which things moved at the
weekend I hadn't had time to sit down
with her one-to-one as would normally be
the practice before parliamentary
exchanges now I understand the role
opposition parties play I've stood at
that dispatch box myself but behind
behind behind the rhetoric and I was
listening very carefully I don't think
she disagreed with a single one of the
decisions that I announced to Parliament
and and that is important for the
country and markets to know and I think
there is also agreement on the process
of policy making I support the
independence of the bank of England
introduced by Gordon Brown and I know
she supports the independence of the obr
set up by George Osborne
the government the whole government
supports the independence of those two
important institutions now
accept
and I don't think I could have been more
clear that we have had to change some
decisions made in the last few weeks but
what I reject what I reject
wholeheartedly is her broader narrative
about conservative economic management
let me remind her let me remind her that
the UK's unemployment rate
is the lowest since 1974.
[Applause]
Italy Canada Belgium Sweden Spain and
the Netherlands and massively lower than
2010. let me remind her that since 2010
our growth rate has been the third
highest in the G7 she may not want to
hear this but these are the economic
facts
our growth rate since this party came
into baz been higher than Germany France
Italy and Japan and faster than any G7
country this year looking to the future
we have the largest technology sector in
Europe more foreign direct Investments
than anywhere in Europe are one country
that is a legacy to be proud of
now I was listening carefully for uh
some questions about the measures that I
announced but she didn't ask any and I
think she agreed with them
um
but but I will pick her up on one points
she talked about the NHS
let me tell her
[Applause]
maybe they don't want to listen about
the NHS she talked about the NHS because
of the global financial crisis which
happened on her party's watch the NHS
went through one of its most difficult
periods ever and this party protected
the NHS budget foreign
2017 we were able to give it its biggest
single increase in funding because of
the difficult decisions that we took and
that party opposed so Mr Speaker uh in
conclusion We inherited a financial
crisis we dealt with a global pandemic
we've led the world in support of
Ukraine possible because of difficult
decisions taken over the last 12 years
each and every one opposed by the party
opposite so if she is preaching today
the need for fiscal credibility which I
warmly welcome
can I just tell her this the true test
will be in two weeks time to see whether
she supports public spending restraint
I've shown conservatives
shown conservatives can raise taxes will
she show labor are willing to restrain
spending
[Applause]
they welcome my right honorable friends
uh statement it was both Frank and bold
and it appears in the very short term at
least two have steadied the markets one
point that my right honorable friend
raised at the dispatch box though was
absent from his statement earlier today
was his renewed commitment to our
financial institutions particularly the
bank of England and the office for
Budget responsibility he has also now
brought forward the economic advisory
Council a number of members of which
have appeared before the treasury select
committee and I think he has chosen well
but could he reassure the house that in
no way the economic advisory Council
will in any way conflict with the bank
of England or the office of budget
responsibility the FCA the pra and all
of our institutions and it'll be there
to complement not work against any of
those institutions
well can I thank uh The Honorable
gentlemen who has spoken very wisely in
recent weeks about the difficult issues
that we face
um I can absolutely give him that
Assurance
um I want to be frank to make sure that
I'm getting advice from Fantastic
institutions like the treasury the bank
of England and the office for Budget
responsibility but also advice that it's
independent of those institutions
because that is the way we'll get the
best result Rupert Harrison in
particular has enormous experience of
running the Treasury under George
Osborne Over many years I think he'll
make a very important contribution as
will his colleagues on the council and
with respect to the markets he's
absolutely right to be cautious about
what happens they go up as well as they
go down and no government can control or
should seek to control the markets what
we can do is the things within our power
and that is a commitment a very firm and
clear commitment to fiscal
responsibility yeah don't come to SMP
spokesperson Allison
[Music]
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
I see that the Prime Minister has been
uh urgently running off to something
else rather than staying to listen Mr
Speaker when the previous Chancellor
came to give as many budget three long
weeks ago I called economic chaos that
put an understatement that turned out to
be I'm not sure words have yet been
invented to describe the scale of the
unmitigated disaster which the Prime
Minister and our chancellors have
created in the past 24 days we're back
where we started significantly worse off
due to Tory incompetence and isn't it
just as well that in Scotland the
Scottish government didn't take the
advice of um Tory MPS to copy and peace
before the front bench here deletes all
you and people will be paying the price
for this for many years to come through
higher interest and borrowing rates
will he apologize for this increased
cost that his colleagues have inflicted
upon people and he has not been clear at
all will he confirm the status of the
Banker's bonus Gap has it been scrapped
or has it not been scrapped
there's little by way of detail from the
current Chancellor on doubling down on
austerity and what that will mean for
people but the institute for government
is set for have been clear that there is
no fat left to cut after a lost decade
for Public Services Under the Tories so
where does the current Chancellor expect
to make these Cuts these efficiency
savings we know what he means when he
says it we already know the terrible
price of austerity because Glasgow
Center for population Health have
attributed 330
000 excess deaths tutorial sterility
policies an unacceptable human cost
again and again the Tories bring forward
harmful policies they never feel the
consequences of
and we know that guarantees me nothing
under the Tories either the so-called
energy price guarantee turns out to be
worth six months not two years a cliff
Edge looming next April National energy
action have said that many vulnerable
people were Holding On by their
fingertips government must be very very
careful it doesn't price them away so
can you tell us exactly what will happen
for households in April the scale of
increases make almost everybody
vulnerable except perhaps as Banker Pals
and what will happen to the most
vulnerable when inflation soars as a
result of despite the return of
spiraling energy costs
the previous Chancellor never got around
to telling me what will happen to
business energy costs at the end of
their six-month reprieve so can the
current Chancellor tell me what support
business is signing impossibly expensive
contracts as we speak can expect
and will this current Chancellor as the
former former former translated commit
to operating benefits with the rate of
inflation and we also increase support
to those languishing in the Asylum
system and end the punishing no recourse
to public funds regime will he cancel
the benefit cap and scrap the two child
limit which is trapping so many children
in poverty where is his compassion for
them will he invest in Renewables carbon
capture and storage and a comprehensive
Energy Efficiency and installation
package and finally Mr Speaker does he
understand does he really understand
when looking at broke broken Britain the
chaos that the Tories have wreaked and
the prospect of oblique brexit future
under both labor and the Tories that
more and more of Scotland's people are
looking at the comprehensive
Independence perspectives set out with
the first Minister today and moving
towards the vision of a failure Greener
more prosperous Scotland back in the
heart of Europe Where We Belong
yeah well
um Mr Speaker it's a pleasure to
exchange comments with the honorable
lady I will look forward to working with
her closely in the months ahead
um I would remind her that this
conservative government is spending 37
billion pounds this year to support
people across the United Kingdom with
cost of living concerns that is possible
because of difficult economic decisions
that the SMP have opposed at nearly
every stage and that includes large
support for businesses up and down the
country but the main thing I would say
to her very gently is that she cannot
claim to be concerned about the economic
turmoil of the last few weeks when the
central policy of the SMP Independence
would leave turmoil for Scotland not for
a few weeks but for many many years to
come a new currency
somehow finding a way to trade with the
UK internal Market but also the European
single Market uh border checks between
England and Scotland as announced today
by the first Minister a massive Gap in
public finances it would have to be a
breach that is a recipe for precisely
the austerity she says she's worried
about
let me say this if we want economic
stability if Scotland wants economic
stability to coin a phrase we are
stronger together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what what will the impact of these
measures beyond the growth rate and will
we still avoid recession
[Music]
publish the economic forecasts from the
obr when I make my statement in a
fortnight's time and I think it's better
for me to wait until I hear that but the
proper answer to his question is that
what we are seeking is long-term
sustainable increase in the economic
growth rate and that is a central policy
of the Prime Minister which has my
wholehearted support hey Barbara Hodge
yeah thank you Mr Speaker I think the
country is feeling a sense of relief the
trickle-down economics has signed has
been so quickly abandoned but there was
one element in the uh mini budget which
the new Chancellor did not address and
that was the issue of investment zones
that is a uh we we have great evidence
all over the place about how that as a
mechanism for encouraging growth and
jobs and prosperity has failed from the
Thatcher years onward all that happens
is they're incredibly expensive we lose
income from them they only lead to the
transfer of jobs from one poor area to
the other and they are a massive
opportunity for every kleptocrat
oligarch and criminal to launder money
into the UK will the chancellor abandon
that policy too
well I would like to say that I have a
great deal of respect for the
campaigning the right honorable lady has
done over many years
against people illicitly hiding wealth
and not paying their share of tax and um
I do totally support the benefits that
investment zones can bring but we will
Implement that policy in a way that
learns the lessons of when models that
are similar have been tried in the past
and we will make sure that they are
successful
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I welcome the
return of an ironclad fiscal
responsibility albeit within the most
velvet of gloves for there can be no
growth without economic credibility but
will you answer this question
when he brings forward the forecast in a
fortnight made by independently by the
office for Budget responsibility will he
guarantee now that they will show debt
falling as a proportion of our income
and show that once we have the finances
fully under control we will not be
borrowing for day-to-day spending
because you cannot put the nation's
spending on the Never Never
yes and yes
because people are already suffering
from the damaged caused by this
government's economic mistakes hundreds
of pounds now added to mortgage bills
pushing millions of families to the
brink on top of higher food prices
higher fuel costs and higher energy
bills
but despite that the chancellor refuses
to undo one of the government's biggest
injustices
failure to impose a proper windfall tax
on the record profits of the oil and gas
companies earned only because Putin is
killing innocent ukrainians after so
many u-turns surely the chancellor can
persuade the prime minister to do one
more Willie introduce a proper windfall
tax and help struggling families
[Applause]
let me tell the right on gentleman I am
not against the principle of taxing
profits that are genuine windfalls but
as he will know very well in the energy
industry it is a very cyclical industry
and there are businesses that have
periods of feast and famine and you have
to be very careful that you don't tax
companies in a way that drives away
investment so we have said that nothing
is off the table
Andrew Mitchell you uh Mr Speaker I want
to congratulate my right honorable
friend on his statement today which is
both wise and necessary and there will
be great relief um across the house that
the markets have responded positively to
my right honorable friend's statement
not least thanks to his economic
leadership and political skill in the
run-up to the 31st of October will he
reassure us and the markets that the
treasurer of Treasury and the obr and
the Independent Bank of England will be
working closely together and in total
Lobster
I I absolutely want to give him that
reassurance and I also want to thank him
as someone who has enormous experiences
to how the city works for the advice
that he gave me over the weekend
um I think one of the best things about
the economic structures we have is the
interaction between institutions which
have Independence and are able to give
independent advice and Treasury and the
government and it has helped create
stability and I hope that what I've said
today will bolster that further
Mr Speaker can I congratulate the
chancellor on his appointment and I hope
he lasts longer than his predecessors
wow five five million people five
million people will see their mortgages
go up and the mini budget Fiasco means
that on average 500 pounds more in
payment and in London nearly 900 can the
chancellor assure us that he's going to
look at how he can take that additional
prime minister's mortgage premium off
people's bills and take action to
protect them in these difficult times
and if you can't should they send the
bill to him
but um
let me say to The Honorable lady that we
have an absolute responsibility as a
government to do everything we can
to hold increases in mortgage rates down
as much as is possible insofar as the
government has an influence on them
through its own actions and that is why
I've taken I think very strong and quick
steps to demonstrate this government's
commitment to fiscal balance but we are
in a world in which unfortunately
interest rates are going up everywhere
and everyone is having to deal with
increases in mortgage rates and we are
thinking about the challenge for people
who have those mortgages but I want to
make sure that that does not happen as a
result of actions by this government
Kevin hollenry
um can I welcome all the measures in his
statement today I think it's absolutely
right they will look for better value
for the taxpayer through spending
restraints but can he confirm any cuts
to spending will not impact on capital
expenditure infrastructure spending
expenditure particularly across the
North and that will fully deliver on
projects that we've already done
committed to such as Northern Powerhouse
rail
so my honorable friend will know
um sorry my voice is a bit croaky at the
moment because I've been probably
talking too much over the last few days
but as my honorable friend will know
there are very important projects that
we all care about a great deal but given
the severity of the situation at the
moment we are not taking anything off
the table uh whether tax increases or
spending reductions but I don't believe
it is possible I don't believe it is
possible to have a long-term credible
economic growth strategy that doesn't
recognize the vital importance of
capital spending
foreign
speaker even a screeching U-turn can't
repair the damage when we've already had
the crash but when the chance for the
dismantled trussonomics overnight why on
Earth did he decide to carry on boosting
Bankers bonuses in the heart of a cost
of living crisis
because the policy didn't work and we
will get more tax from Rich Bankers with
the policy we now have
Greg Clark Mr Speaker I welcome the
Chancellor's statement if there are
further steps that are required will he
do whatever it takes to restore the UK's
fiscal credibility
I will Samuels
first of all can I welcome the
appointment of the chancellor and wish
him well in his job because his success
uh on his success depends the success of
all of our constituents and meeting the
cost of living whilst inflation cannot
be blamed on the government because it's
an international and whilst interest
rates are going up across the world
the one thing we should answer is fully
responsible for is today's increase in
taxation which will take money from
people at a vital time enabling them to
pay not able to pay their bills or their
investment plans I assume he has done
some economic modeling in this what
impact does he believe it will have on
growth and on the burden of debt in
relational GDP over the next two years
closed captioning not available
in a positive direction on National
finances but unfortunately it won't be
the end of the story if we're going to
deliver
a credible budget in which we can
demonstrate as my writer or friend asked
earlier that debt is falling as a
percentage of GDP by the end of the
period then we're going to have further
difficult decisions ahead and this
government won't show it from them hello
weekly thank you Mr Speaker a pandemic
followed by a war our constituents do
not expect this time to be easy but they
do expect us to set out the difficult
choices to make the difficult choices
and then set out the path for a better
future
can I ask my right honorable friend
particularly in considering his
experiences of many years
to continue to press ahead with our
commitment to reform social care knowing
as he does that social care and the NHS
go hand in hand and again how important
they are to our constituents
[Music]
well she and I have had very many
discussions on social care over the
years mainly when I've been a
backbencher and she's been a minister
and it is a sector that is in great
difficulty at the moment I'm very aware
of those concerns I'm also very aware of
the pressures in the NHS at the moment
I'm not making any commitments as to
what exactly we will do but as I said
earlier all these decisions will be
taken through the prism of what matters
most to the people who need the help the
most today I'm Angela thank you uh Mr
Speaker the chancellor has
um put a brute lend to the
self-proclaimed New Era of trussonomics
with his announcements and he's taken
away 32 billion pounds worth of planned
tax cuts according to the institute for
fiscal studies that still leaves a 30
billion pound hole in his sums and if
rumors are correct it could be as high
as 40 billion if the obr calculations
that I've heard about her correct that
means surely doesn't it Mr Speaker
austerity 2.0 to at least the same size
as the first level of austerity we had
from 2010 uh to 2015 at surely at Mr
Speaker
the chancellor must know that public
services simply cannot deal with that
level of cuts when they've been so
weakened by austerity the first round of
austerity
um let me say to the radical lady I I
was a cabinet minister in 2010 when we
had very difficult decisions to take in
the wake of the financial crisis
and my Department's budget was cut by 24
and I don't believe we are talking about
anything of that scale
um and I think it's likely that cash
spending will continue to go up but that
said I want to be completely Frank with
people we are going to have very
difficult decisions both on tax and
spending in the next couple of weeks we
will try and take those decisions as
compassionately as possible
so it's going to be tough going forward
but I don't expect it to be on the scale
that she suggests sure Edward Italy I
congratulate that Chancellor on his
soothing and competent tone and of
course we've got to calm the markets but
what is our vision
of course we accept the shortcomings of
course we accept the short carvings of
the mini budget
but does he accept we can't just slide
into a sort of second-rate economy and
go in the direction of France with a
bloated a bloated public sector the
higher taxes for 70 years gross
inefficiencies so by the time the next
election can we as a conservative party
promise to get taxation back at least
the level it was when we started the
parts of this Parliament and get
Corporation back to the one of the most
competitive in Europe otherwise what is
the point of the conservative party
[Applause]
he he is here's the problem Mr Speaker
with uh all the noises we're getting
from the party opposite this
compassionate conservative government
was able to step in with massive help
from members of the public with the
furlough scheme
energy price guarantee because we took
difficult decisions on the economy in
the years that proceeded it each and
every one that was opposed by the party
opposite
I I say to my right honorable friends
of government is to build a strong
economy that's what we will do
it's an important point I wish to make
Mr Speaker it is the job of a Chancellor
not just to balance the books but also
to have a vision for economic growth and
I hope I will persuade him in two weeks
time that I have just that have a
holiday thank you Mr Speaker does the
chancellor agree with the Prime Minister
who confirmed that the state pension
would rise with inflation in April and
if he does agree can he commit to it
today
well I'm very aware
of how many vulnerable pensioners there
are and the importance of the triple
lock but as I said earlier I'm not
making any commitments on any individual
policy areas but every decision we take
will be taken through the prism of what
matters most to the most vulnerable Mark
Harper
speaker can I thank the chancellor for
his robust defense of conservative
Economic Policy over the last 12 years
more of that please am I in a chartered
accountant can't but help welcome the
fact that he's reassured me that it is
the treasurer's job essential task to
make sure the sums add up can you ask me
a little bit about the review of the
energy price guarantee it's right I
think to focus taxpayer support on those
that need it most but can I draw it his
attention that one seventh of the
population are not on the gas grid 40 of
my constituents are not as he designs
that system to protect the most
vulnerable can you make sure it works
for everyone in the country wherever
they live and however they Heat their
homes
well I look forward to lots of useful
advice from his inner accountant over
the months and years ahead I will
certainly bear that point in mind
um the issue with the revised scheme
that we want to announce for the energy
price guarantee is that I think most
people agree with the logic of targeting
support where it's needed the most but
we need a scheme that works practically
and is not actually particularly easy to
design that kind of scheme so we're
going to do as much work as we can we'll
announce uh what we're going to do as
soon as we can but we'll certainly bear
in mind the points you made John
McDonald
the back the backdrop to today's
statement isn't just the chaos of the
last Fortnight it is also a report of
three weeks ago that demonstrated as a
result of austerity there has been over
300 000 excess deaths
can I ask him in his preparations for
the 31st of October that he recognizes
that unless he increases benefits by at
least the rate of inflation there will
be more excess deaths and suffering yeah
he will know because I've I've said it
many times today that I'm not making
firm commitments on any individual
elements of tax and spending but I hope
he is reassured that I've been very
clear about the values through which we
will take those decisions Mr early thank
you Mr Speaker I congratulate my right
honorable friends he has hit the ground
running at this job these are difficult
decisions they're the correct decisions
right now we all aspire to tax cuts in
the future but he's right that we
actually have to have the money to pay
for those but could I ask him as he
prepares for the 31st of October to look
in details how we address what is the
most in my view deep rooted problem this
country faces and has done for decades
which is our current account deficit we
will not truly get rid of these issues
until we restore a better balance in our
national finances kind of ask him to
make that a priority
well I thank my right honorable friend
for his his question and and I agree
ultimately it is not sustainable to have
a permanent current account deficit and
that is something we need to address
Bentley
Chancellor announced that he will be
reviewing the energy price guarantee
um but does the government have any
plans to review the level of support
offered off grid properties with the
cost of the heating bills this winter
there's cross-party consensus for the
100 pounds payment is an adequate to
meet the rising level of bills so will
he bring forward further support in
advance to this winter year
well I've listened carefully to what the
original honorable gentleman said as I
did to my honorable friend from Forest
of Dean and we will certainly look
carefully at what can be done for
off-grid properties
thank you Mr Speaker can I welcome the
necessary but vigorous course
Corrections that uh my original friend
has introduced he began his statement by
saying that Central responsibilities of
any government they also include
security defense of Britain support to
our allies and standing up to our
adversaries as we've done so in Ukraine
my right old friend knows the world's
getting more dangerous not less will he
commit to continuing that uh promise of
three percent GDP defense spend
well it won't be a secret to my right
honorable friend that I'm uh sympathetic
to that because I've campaigned for it
when I was a backbencher very loudly and
visibly but all of these things have to
be sustainable any increase in defense
spending has to be an increase that we
can sustain over very many years let me
just say to him today that I agree with
him entirely that the duty of a
government is security for the
population in all senses of the word
Steve McKay
thank you does the uh Chancellor's
compassionate conservatism extend to
raising the minimum income component of
pension credit or is he prepared to let
the poorest pensioners in the line be
sacrificed in the altar of trust
economics
what I gently say to him
is that whilst I completely understand
how important it is to support our most
vulnerable pensioners what they need
more than anything is a strong economy
that can pay for the support that we
would want to give them seven hole can I
welcome my right Uncle friend to his
place and uh
really the sigh of relief of the
grown-up and sensible approach which is
taken to the issues at hand can I also
Echo the remarks of my wife and
girlfriend for The Forest of Dean and
The Honorable member for carradigian of
the need for my original girlfriend to
take into account those who are off-grid
and using heating oil they deserve as
much support as we possibly can I write
on my friend is newly empowered and he
is able to slay many dragons could he
say the dragon of fracking which was not
in our Manifesto yeah
this is an issue that's risen its head
in my own constituency
um let me simply say to him the
government's position is very clear we
will not proceed unless there is local
support for a light Lucas thank you Mr
Speaker in the bonfire of government
policy that's just taken place the
chancellor wasn't very specific about
what would happen to the prime
minister's investment Zone policy
personally I was hoping that it would be
incinerated as well not least because it
is designed to undermine environmental
regulation to avoid Fair Taxation and
bypass local democracy now in the past
he has said that he is a green Tory I
have to put it to him that that is sadly
an endangered species right now but if
he's serious about being a green tour he
will he now take steps to demonstrate it
by ruling out any policies that will
undermine nature protection and
restoration and will he accept that
there is no Financial Capital that is
not entirely dependent on a thriving
natural capital
I am absolutely committed to protecting
our green spaces and boosting
biodiversity
um but I also think it's important to
look at environmental regulations to see
if they can be streamlined in a way that
is consistent with allowing the natural
world to flourish as well as the economy
what's Raven can I welcome and thank the
chancellor for bringing so quickly a
calm reassurance to the markets and to
this crisis would you agree with me that
economic crisis based on political
confidence mean everybody in this
chamber both sides of the house have a
duty to reassure the markets that we're
capable of taking tough decisions and
would he second agree with me that as we
look to grow as he's highlighted the
technology and science areas provide
huge opportunity and we should resist
the opportunity to cut funding
there is no more formidable advocate of
Science and Technology than my right
honorable friend and I think he knows
that I also care very much about that
sector and with respect to reassuring
the markets I think the most important
thing is as we said earlier that there
is actually no disagreement about the
policies announced today and I think
it's important for the markets to know
there is that consensus in the house
then Daniel Johnson
speaker last month the Prime Minister
told the BBC in Hull that we would be
included in the northern Powerhouse rail
despite not being included in the
government's integrated rail plan so I
want to know was the Prime Minister
wrong to say that to the BBC in Hull
I don't know but I'll write and tell her
talk to Julia Lewis Mr Speaker may I
warmly welcome the Chancellor's earlier
remarks about defense and security as it
took us very many years to pay off this
country's colossal second world war debt
am I right in thinking that the huge
costs of covid and of Putin's aggression
in Ukraine cannot possibly be cleared
completely in the short to medium term
enough
well
um I wish I could answer that question
but as he will know better than me
this appalling Saga is far from over so
we don't know what the total costs are
going to be
um I thank him for his uh very rapid not
entirely unexpected lobbying on defense
budget issues since I took up this post
and what I would say to him is that I
think the job of the chance of its
Checker is to make sure that our economy
is strong enough to fund the role that
Britain wants to play in the defense of
democracy and freedom all over the world
speaker I have worked with and against
the chance of checker on many occasions
and I've learned he's an honest man but
can I tell him today that he just said
in his remarks that this country is
always good at rising to the challenge
of big and difficult times can I tell
him what I hate about what he said today
really do think about it is there was no
note of Contrition this big and bad was
started by his lot only two weeks ago
and it's not just big and bad it's a
national disaster that he did not one
word give one word of condition about a
mess he's made this his parties made of
this country
well all I would say to
um The Honorable general of whom I do
have the greatest respect we are many
many exchanges in this house over the
years is that I think actions speak
louder than words and I don't think I
could have been plainer and going out
this weekend and what I've said today in
accepting that mistakes were made but
what the country wants to see is us
correcting those mistakes and that's
what we've done Steve Bryan my rightful
friend knows that I'm very pleased to
see him in Downing Street and the sense
of relief expressed to me this weekend
as I've been out and about in my
constituency was palpable I welcome his
statement I welcome its realism it's
honesty and his trademark sense of
optimism in his final remarks which I
certainly could learn from he's right
that growth demands confidence so does
he have confidence that when the bank
make their decisions a week or so after
his statement in two weeks time that a
rise in interest rates which is
terrifying my constituents the mere
Prospect of it is not inevitable
um well I think my writable friend was
generous comments I I just say this it's
not for the government uh to say what
the bank of England does when the
monetary policy committee makes its
decision on interest rates
um but of course I've had conversations
with the governor to ask him what it is
the bank needs to hear for them to feel
that the inflationary pressures will be
lower and they would not have to make as
high an increase as perhaps some people
are predicting and thinking about the
concerns of our constituents mortgages
is top of my mind
austerity with public spending cards
squeezing services that have already
been cut to the boat over the past 12
years this is without a mandate and like
before this round of austerity is a
political choice not an economic
necessity so instead of cutting our
services the government could raise
taxes on the super rich and if the
chancellor believes in his approach why
doesn't it put it to the people and call
for a general election
with the greatest respect to the
honorable lady I did not pledge as she
said I think a new wave of austerity
what I would say to her if she doesn't
like austerity look at the generosity of
the furlough scheme look at the
generosity of what we're doing on the
cost of living crisis all taken because
of difficult decisions that she's
opposed every time Richard Drex okay can
I welcome my right old friend to his
place he talks about growing the economy
and a strong economy and I'd agree with
that can I just remind the house
particularly on the opposition benches
that it is in the main the private
sector that raises the money that pays
the tax for the public sector and we
cannot go on hammering the private
sector if you want to seek the growth
that we want so can I ask about my
friend as he takes his place and I
really do welcome him there that he
Bears this in mind and reduces taxation
as soon as he's able to
all right
the answer is yes and
to demonstrate that I understand what
he's talking about when he talks about
the private sector I'm going to say some
words that I've always dreamed of saying
from behind this dispatch box which is
that I used to be an entrepreneur
[Applause]
quite faced in the future I hope he's
not going to fall into the old trap of
trying to cut his way to growth it can't
work it never works but can I actually
welcome what he did today the screeching
you tongue on the vast majority of the
mini budget from the Prime Minister and
his predecessor but given he's done that
and I do welcome it can we have a
guarantee from him today the so long as
he has anything to do with it there will
never be a return to extremist crank
experimental Think Tank economics
I'm happy to offer that guarantee if he
will agree to explicitly reject the
extremist crank Think Tank economics of
Scottish independence
[Applause]
[Music]
uh thank you very much Mr Speaker I
welcome the
um direction of travel of my right
honorable friend and also the
restatement of compassionate
conservatism which is at the heart of
this political uh party
um could I just ask my right honorable
friend that when the previous government
had to rightly cut the the conservative
government under chance of George
Osborne had to cut the deficit cut debt
they also helped uh the most needy with
the cost of living introducing the
living wage and cutting taxes for lower
earners introducing a fuel Duty uh
freeze but they also invested in skills
and apprenticeships and I know he's not
going to give me an answer now but could
I ask him will that be his guiding
philosophy as he goes forward in his new
role
well I always listen to my honorable
friend very carefully on these issues
let me say to him this that I don't
think we will solve the growth Paradox
of this country raising our long-term
rate of economic growth to two and a
half percent from from under one percent
unless we tackle the skills issue it is
absolutely essential I don't promise
that I can give him an entire solution
to that in two weeks time but it's
something I'd very much like to talk to
you more about I'm prior Mr Speaker
um government insiders are busy telling
the press that the bank of England is
playing roulette that's in quotes with
the British economy is that helpful or
unhelpful
well those comments have not been
covered from the government since I have
been a part of it I can't talk about
what happened before but what I will say
is that I am working extremely closely
with the bank of England and we are both
absolutely aligned on the need for
stability James
speaker and
one friend welcome to his post is one of
the crucial what's that one of the
weaknesses of the plan for growth is
that fiscal and monetary policy were
effectively contradicting one another
and that when we talk about working with
the bank of England what that really
means is fiscal monetary policy working
in lockstep so that we deal with
inflation which is actually the biggest
economic challenge we face
he's actually answered the previous
question much better than I did the
answer is yes
I'm sorry
it is quite right that the chancellor is
he
is six year at the markets but what do
you take the opportunity today to also
to reassure the millions of people who
rely on benefits for people who are in
work and people who are out of work the
UK is some of the lowest benefits in
Europe people on benefits with no plan B
they have no savings and they have huge
anxiety are present they're given the
current situation so can we pledge the
benefits will increase in live existing
government policy and lie with the CPI
and also will he reverse what the
previous Chancellor said it is very
budget around the more premium approach
to be taken against those and benefits
well what I would say to him is just
very straightforward it's because I want
us to be able to support the poorest the
most vulnerable people in the greatest
difficulties in society that I think the
most important thing I can do right now
as Chancellor is what I can to create
economic stability and that's what I'm
doing
Alex talk thank you madam Deputy speaker
I warmly welcome the Chancellor's Swift
and decisive action today but also the
tone and above all the Candor of his
remarks does the chancellor agree with
me that the best way to build in the
long term a strong economy and a fair
Society of my constituents in Charlton
many of whom he met recently is to
repair the public finances in the short
term that's the conservative way that's
what builds prosperity in the long term
absolutely and um only a couple of weeks
ago I was sitting in a cafe in
Cheltenham having a cold sandwich with
him
um and I also want to thank him for his
incredible articulacy in lobbying for
the needs of the people of Cheltenham
Stephen kinner thank you madam Deputy
speaker does the chancellor think that
it's morally justifiable to lift the cap
on Bankers bonuses whilst refusing to
confirm that he will link uh benefits to
inflation is it morally justifiable I I
understand why he's asked the question
and I believe that wealthier people
should pay more as we go through a
difficult period but I think the
mechanism that we were doing that with
the cat wasn't working and we will get
more money out of the pockets of those
Rich Bankers by what we're going to do
now
flip Drummond
Deputy speaker many of our more advanced
manufacturing businesses are in the
defense sector and they welcome our
commitment to a growing defense spending
they have no problem with paying more
corporation tax as long as they're
incentive to support their cutting-edge
research and development will my right
honorable friend commit to ensure that
those incentives are available across
all Industries
um well I think that's a very
um
important Point we've we've got an issue
that we need our companies to invest
more in r d we've got I think a
fantastic opportunity to be the world's
next Silicon Valley with all the
potential of our great universities and
incredible levels of innovation but I
absolutely think there's more we can do
and I'll bear in mind our comments
thank you madam Deputy speaker since
2015 the the value of the pounds dropped
about 30 compared to the dollar after
this government's money budget the the
pound heart and all-time low against the
dollar or govern oil and gas and other
related Energy Products are trading and
dollars isn't it the case it'd be
absolutely tanking the pound against the
dollar this government's actually added
other course Tower at the cost of energy
in the UK yeah yeah well I'm delighted
that someone from the SMP is worried
about the value of the pound and I think
that shows it matters to all of us and I
would say to him I would say to him I
would I would say to him
I would say to him in all seriousness
governments cannot control the value of
currency and should not seek to do so
but insofar as our actions affect the
stability of our markets including the
currency markets the one thing we can do
is show that we're balancing the books
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd like to welcome the new Chatsworth
in his new position
um my right honorable friend my friend
and I would also Madam Deputy speak you
wouldn't know this but my right
honorable friend should have been coming
to Malcolm on Thursday but of course
last weekend has changed these things
however I would extend
um invitation to come to Malcolm to see
how much money has been spent there how
it has been doing very well since 2010
and come and see the Eden Project North
site and the stakeholders
[Applause]
I'd be delighted to accept his
invitation and um he might not want to
tell me what he'd like as a christening
present for his daughter because I've
now got a trillion pounds at my disposal
Deputy speaker in the history of British
democracy have we ever had such a
calamitous start from for a prime
minister and now four chancellors in
four months but it was a majority of
conservative MPS and members who
inflicted Upon Our Country the fantasy
Trussell uh trickle-down economics when
they naively decided to take a break a
holiday from reality which has left many
of my slowest constituents struggling to
pay their bills so does the new
Chancellor given that he is effectively
dumped the Kamikaze mini budget does he
agree that he and the prime minister no
longer have a democratic mandate to
continue in their positions and that
they should step aside and let the
exasperated British people uh make their
decision
or order just before the chancellor
answers that question and responds to
the the very neat speech that The
Honorable gentleman has just made I must
appeal to colleagues for quick questions
we've had all the speeches we don't need
to hear all the same thing all over
again quick question so that the
chancellor can give brief replies
because otherwise we'll never get on to
the other business
Chancellor
I don't think a general election would
contribute to stability if people had to
worry about the disastrous policies of a
future labor government
thank you
you just pursued them all
good
Deputy speaker I know that the decisions
the chance was taking today you would
not have taken easily but he will
recognize that the planned increases in
alcohol duties will have a devastating
impact on many uh small pubs small
Brewers and Hospitality businesses will
he will he look at how the changes he is
making to be a duty in particular can be
structured to help rather than harm
these small Hospitality businesses and
perhaps bring forward the implementation
of draft beer juicy
[Applause]
I I do hear my honorable friend in the
hospitality industry is incredibly
important for our economy and I just say
two things first of all um as he knows
we are reviewing the whole structure of
uh duties when it comes to alcohol and
as part of that process we will be
keeping the levels of Duty under
constant review
[Applause]
made that is massively relevant to
Cumbria and other rural communities the
cut in stamp Duty will help nearly
nobody who can currently not afford a
home to be able to afford one what it
will do is add fuel to the fire of a
second homeownership an Airbnb disaster
in areas like the lakes and The Dales
will he understand the damaged accessive
second home ownership and Airbnb does to
communities like mine and indeed other
parts of the country what do you think
again do something to support our
communities and to stop the housing
catastrophe
I do entirely understand the concerns of
second homeowners and the government has
been looking at that policy in enormous
detail over recent months but I would
gently say to him that it would be wrong
to be dismissive of the concerns of
young people desperately trying to get
onto the housing ladder and the help we
are giving them with the stamp Duty
reforms will make a significant
difference
I pay tribute to the chancellor for his
statement done for the urgency in which
uh he's he's taken them the energy price
guarantee was welcomed across the house
although that is probably the policy
that created the greatest uncertainty in
the financial markets does my right
honorable friend agree as he reviews the
policy that they will continually be
challenges in this area so long as Putin
maintains his aggressive conflict in the
Ukraine yeah
absolutely and I'm very pleased that he
made that point because we should
remember that Putin's game is to try and
turn economic instability into Political
instability and we must not play along
with it
Stephen Doty thank you Matt Deputy
speaker the chaos in the bond markets
impacting on pensions whereas result
Decisions by his government his party
his prime minister can he now tell us
are all Pension funds secure what is the
value of the total losses and what
actions will he be taking to ensure that
people can have confidence in their
pensions why should they ever trust the
Tories with their pensions again
I'm afraid I don't accept his analysis
of why those problems happened at all
um but I don't deny that we have had
some issues uh with Pension funds but I
would just point him to the governor of
the bank of England's statement today
that says that we are well on our way to
resolving them
Jack Burton you madam Deputy speaker
people and businesses across
Stoke-on-Trent are incredibly thankful
for the support with energy bills
throughout the winter so will my right
or more friend look at when he comes to
review these policies in April to make
sure that those who most need that
support protected most and particularly
those energy-intensive businesses like
Ceramics in Stoke-on-Trent
girlfriend will be pleased to know that
I've already had discussions extensive
discussions with my treasury officials
about the needs of energy intensive
Industries and we're very well aware of
those issues
just Phillips Deputy speaker it seems
quite baffling to me that everybody
giving the the and I welcome him to his
place applaudits for all the work he's
done and well done when the thing that
he is undoing
was the prime minister's budget as if
it's as if the last four weeks haven't
happened and I feel a tiny bit gaslit by
it I have to say so why is he spending
two billion pounds a year on unfunded
stamp Duty cuts when he said today he
couldn't announce unfunded tax cuts so
how is he going to pay for that
she'll find out in two weeks
100 jokes
to say it's very
very much humble friend in his place
does he agree that as well as supporting
families and businesses now with energy
bills the need for long-term energy
resilience is as urgent as ever will
that be one of his priorities
it will not just my responsibility but
out of the whole government because I
think a good government is about fixing
long-term issues as well as dealing with
short-term prices and that is definitely
a very very important long-term issue
Jeremy corbyn and I'm Deputy speaker we
live in a deeply divided country in a
deeply divided Society there are more
poor people than ever there's more
people accessing food banks than ever
before and there are more children
growing up in absolute poverty and as a
result of that not achieving their best
in life twice he's refused to answer the
question about whether he will raise
benefits in line with inflation for a
third time can he please assure those
people who rely on benefits for their
very existence that they will be
increased at least in line with
inflation to tackle the appalling
poverty that so many people face
well I
um respect the right honorable gentleman
for pressing me on that issue because I
understand how important it is and let
me say to him the reason I'm not able to
give him the answer he seeks is because
I'm not giving that answer on any area
of spending or any tax policy the
situation we face is extremely grave and
we have to look at these issues in the
round and we will come to the house with
those decisions just as soon as they
have been made and also independently
audited by the office for Budget
responsibility
Laura virus
speaker I welcome the rapid grip my
right honorable friend has exerted on
the public finances it's been reflected
throughout the day by the rally in
Sterling and guilts but can I seek
clarification of his comments on
investment relief will he maintain his
commitment to seed Enterprise investment
schemes focused on Science and
Technology they are thriving sectors in
my constituency and as he alluded to
they are the engines of our future
economic success
love well I um ran a small technology
business for 14 years so it's very much
where my heart is and I think there's a
massive opportunity for the UK to create
something a bit like the city of London
something you can really pay an enormous
amount of corporate tax for many many
years to come so I just want to say to
her now although I can't give her the
answer I am determined to grip that
opportunity
big Wishard if the chancellor would like
to take this opportunity to concede that
he is now the de facto prime minister
and is he that calls the shots in
government and what must be the most
bizarre and surreal coup in political
history but I'm wondering in this new
role does he think that the current
prime minister is a help or a hindrance
to his economic objectives
um
I just say this
um
it is the most challenging form of
leadership to accept the decision you
have made has to be changed and the
Prime Minister has done that and she has
done so willingly because she
understands the importance of economic
stability and I respect her for it
you can leave
well I'm Deputy speaker and I welcome my
honorable friend to his place
would my honorable friend please give
the constituents my constituents of
Blythe Valley and assurance that this
conservative government will continue to
support the most vulnerable in society
with their energy bills in the months
ahead
uh I will absolutely give that assurance
and I will say to him his own background
is in mental health and he understands I
just how vulnerable people can get and
those concerns will be taught most of
our mind
Grant Davis
it's um will the chancellor before he
goes on a spending cut spree of Public
Services look at the analysis in today's
Financial Times that says for every
pound invested in the NHS it generates
four pounds in growth and we also do
what he can to protect poorly paid uh
health workers who are facing much
higher mortgage costs due to his
government
until he got to the end bit I was going
to say that sounds like the question I
should have been asking the previous
Chancellor as chair of the Health and
Social care select committee I'm very
aware of how the NHS doesn't just cost
us money but can contribute to our
growth and I think there is an enormous
opportunity for this country to become
one of the life science Giants in the
world
Robin Walker
my right honorable friend is placing his
focus on both uh fiscal responsibility
and compassionate conservatism further
history to his very welcome answer to my
right humble friend from Harlow would he
agree that that money invested in the
skills and the education of the most
disadvantaged is money well spent which
will benefit like the fiscal growth and
stability of our country in the future
I absolutely do and I think there are
many economists
um like Paul Johnson who would say that
if we really want to have the the
productivity the levels of wealth and
prosperity of places like Germany and
Singapore then the skills Gap is the
biggest Gap we have I think it's
scandalous that for decades governments
of all sides of this house have not been
able to deal with the fact that around a
hundred thousand people leave school
every year unable to read and I think
these are very important issues but I
want to be honest this is not something
I'm going to be able to address or the
government's going to be able to address
in the next two weeks but is absolutely
something we'll have to come back to
Chris bribes thank you madam speaker
um for all the handwringing and soft so
I'm afraid I don't think this one's any
better than the last chance
um well he's been present at all the
failures over the last 12 years the
failure to invest in the NHS the failure
to make sure that we had PPE in time for
a pandemic the failure to deal properly
with the invasion of Ukraine under uh in
and the annexation of Crimea and all of
them he has been there at scene of the
crime and the biggest problem is we will
now have as a result of 12 Years of Tory
economics we will have the highest tax
take in our history and still the
highest borrowing in our history and
probably the largest tax cuts in our
history why is this the only country the
only major economy in the world that has
not yet grown to the level that it was
before the pandemic
I actually have a lot of respect for The
Honorable gentleman as a great
parliamentarian but will he allow me to
say that there isn't really a polite
word to describe the nonsense that he's
just said
[Music]
we inherited the worst financial crisis
since the second world war from his
party and since then we are the third
highest growing country in the G7 he
talked about the NHS which had a 20
billion increase in funding on my watch
40 000 more doctors nurses and other
donations and there's more to come if we
take the difficult decisions to grow our
economy that his party always opposes
holy mummy crops just I'm Deputy speaker
my own will find the chancellor knows
very well the importance of Steel both
to my skin thought constituency and to
our country will he confirm that the
energy support package for business
remains unaltered and that when the
treasury enters into the three-month
review they will do so mindful of the
Strategic value of Steel yeah
yes and yes
Toby Perkins thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker firstly when the
chancellor gets too sweet can he
withdraw the claim that labor opposed to
furlough because actually we didn't we
supported uh further but secondly the
chancellor uh was of the view the
previous Chancellor was of the view that
if you reduce corporation tax more money
came back in revenue and indeed uh in
his own short-lived leadership contest
uh he seemed to be saying the same thing
he proposed even greater cuts to
cooperation test so can he now tell us
does he believe that an increase in
corporation tax will raise more revenue
or what has he previously said left
um let me just say this to to The
Honorable gentleman I didn't say that
labor opposed the furlough scheme what I
said is you like it when we spend money
but you oppose all the measures
necessary for the economy to be able to
afford them and when it comes to
corporation tax I would love to reduce
corporation tax and in the long run I
think you do get more money well I'm
answering his question you do get more
money back but it has to be there to be
money that you actually have it can't be
on borrowed money and that's why we have
changed Direction
Magnum speaker and I'm utterly delighted
to see the right honorable gentleman in
his place and it was an honor to be on
his campaign team at the very beginning
but can I just add can I just add one
small point which is last week I met
with the hospitality and tourism sector
they see the possibility of 10 000
businesses going out of business can I
ask whether or not he will meet with me
and representatives from the hospitality
and tourism sector to talk about what we
can do to keep that sector open because
it is absolutely the PowerHouse of the
British economy
but after his generous comments the
answer is absolutely yes
they've raised the prospect of further
departmental savings he actually means
Cuts but from the TUC to the ifg and the
Welsh local government Association it's
agreed that there's nothing left to cut
so when will the chancellor listen to
the wealth tax commission and others
urging the government to raise tax on
wealth and non-earnings income rather
than decimate public services that our
constituents rely on
we already with conservative support ask
wealthier people to pay far more tax
than people on low means but the kind of
taxes that she is advocating will
destroy the wealth of the overall
economy I mean we have less money for
the NHS and for people who need the most
John Stevenson
um I appreciate the chance to have some
really difficult decisions on tax and
spending but if we are to grow the
economy we must maintain the capital
expenditure that we have up and down the
country there are a number of projects
or allocated funding three four years
ago that are now out to Tender that can
be built in the next 12 to 18 months but
they may have a slight shortfall will
the chancellor be sensitive to those
projects because if they are to if we
are to grow the economy it is these sort
of capital projects that we need to
start
look I absolutely agree about the
importance of capital to the long-term
growth of the economy and indeed not
just those projects but many other
projects so yes we'll be sensitive to it
but I'm afraid that doesn't mean that we
won't have to take difficult decisions
right um The Honorable gentleman
disappeared before my very eyes
um
um I'm Ronnie Cohen
all right they're falling they're
falling like nine pins my goodness me we
better try something different Kirsten
Oswald thank you madam Deputy speaker
and he reported that by the number 10
we're briefing the the Chancellor's
statement was due to unspecified Global
headwinds rather than the mini budget
but the former deputy governor of the
bank of England Charles being disagreed
and said that the prime minister's
insistence that the UK's economic
turmoil was a global phenomenon was just
disingenuous so to be clear what does
the chancellor believe has happened here
who does he agree with who does he think
is responsible for the terrible
Financial thumping that my constituents
are now being affected by
I don't think I could have been clearer
in my statement I said that the terminal
we've had is as a result of
international and domestic factors
Jerome thank you Deputy speaker the
chancellor will be aware that his
actions over the last few days has
already lowered long-term expectations
for interest rates so can my right
honorable friend set out for the house
what impact he anticipates that will
have on mortgage rates in my
constitutions have broadened and across
the country as well as on the
government's ability to fund future
services
well I absolutely salute him for uh
thinking about the needs of families
having to pay mortgages which have an
enormous impact on their finances but as
I have learned in my short time in this
job chancellors never comment on what
mortgage rates or interest rates should
be but I absolutely want to make sure
that insofar as the government can
influence it we make sure that they're
held down as low as possible
Andrew go in that's I'll be a bit more
generous and can I genuinely welcome the
re-emphasis on Market stability on sound
economic finance and ensuring that our
country genuinely has an economic policy
that isn't going to frighten the markets
um the chancellor says that he is
reviewing all tax and spending ahead of
the budget and he wants to ensure that
he takes communities with him can I just
impress on him the very real damage that
was done in lots of communities across
this country that one might call the red
wall seats but not all of them voted for
the conservatives in 2019 through the
cuts to local government 60 pence in the
pound local government cannot take that
level of cut again so can I ask him to
at least consider ensuring those
communities are protected
well I'm not making any commitments on
individual areas of any tax or spend but
I absolutely do understand the pressures
faced in local government yes
Madam Deputy speaker can I welcome the
chance for this place can I welcome what
he said about economic stability and
stability is brought and also what he
said about protecting the most
vulnerable which I know my constituents
will welcome when the people of
Newcastle underlying voted for me and
for this government in 2019 they wanted
to deliver brexit deliver us from the
labor party but also Deliver Us leveling
up and despite the difficult economic
circumstances can the chancellor
reassure me can the chancellor reassure
me that this government will continue to
spread opportunity and growth and
investment across this nation
I'm absolutely uh delighted to give that
Assurance I think that it's a
fundamental part of the conservative
philosophy that Economic Opportunity
should be evenly shared across the
country and we accept that it isn't at
the moment
Aleister Carmichael
chief executive of the Scotch whiskey
Association made the point this morning
that time after time freezes in spirit's
Duty has delivered more Revenue to the
treasury contrary to all the forecasts
from the treasury
the translator will know that that is
correct so why does he think it would be
different this time
well I will happily take that uh piece
of wisdom away to the treasury and ask
them to re-look at the figures but I
don't think it's likely they would have
advised me uh to take the measures that
I took today if that was the case but I
will go and ask them to look at it again
Peter older Deputy speaker I welcome my
right honorable friend to his new role
and I commend him for the prompt and
decisive action that he has already
taken he has likely said that the
government wished to protect the most
vulnerable and with this in mind taking
into account the parameters that he has
already set out can I urge him as soon
as practically possible to confirm that
benefits will be uprated in line with
inflation in doing so he will be
removing a burden of worry and anxiety
that is hanging over a great many people
in this country at the current time
well that issue has been raised by a
number of uh colleagues from across the
house and as I said previously I thank
him for raising it I understand how
important the issue is he'll understand
that I'm not in a position to make any
commitment in any area today uh we will
make our decisions as soon as we can and
then bring them back to this house but I
hear what he says
the speaker SE 20 Cycles in my
constituency is a popular bike shop and
the proud home of penge cycle club the
owner Winnie is facing an energy bill of
eleven thousand pounds before winter has
even started and it's only through the
support of a local crowdfunder that
Winnie is able to keep his doors open so
what does the chancellor have to say to
sc20 cycles and the thousands of small
businesses like them that face higher
energy bills higher rents higher prices
and frankly the terrifying uncertainty
because of this government's
incompetence yeah
but we we introduced the energy price
guarantee precisely because we care
about families and also businesses that
are facing unexpected increases in their
fuel bills so I'll write to her to tell
her exactly how we're supporting small
businesses in her constituents
to his place there's a great first step
in restoring trust and confidence in our
economy and while I welcome the broader
package of energy support measures can I
Echo Sentiments of other honorable
members and those of my constituents
from cowsill Village Hall where I met
this weekend up in rural weirdale we're
very concerned about the extra costs of
being off-grid and if you could look at
that over the next couple of weeks it'll
be massively appreciated and would you
also keep working on that broader energy
security measures so that we can ensure
that we don't face this situation again
in the future
Chancellor absolutely do that
Gavin Newlands
brexit merited not one mention any
statement because the truth is modern
deputies because this economic crisis it
was a was baked in when I was partly
committed to a hard brexit it was just a
matter of when although prime minister
substantially brought that forward the
then Member of Parliament for Southwest
sorry said that service levels and
investment in public service would be
massively impacted by brexit so did the
chancellor agree with the then member
for Southwest sorry
[Laughter]
I'm very sorry
um I no I missed the last part of his
question
um and so I I want to give him I'm not
sure if he's allowed to say it again but
on the uh on the first part of this
question I would just simply say that
when it comes to brexit the UK grew
faster than the Eurozone countries since
2016. so I don't accept his analysis
James Morris
thank you madam Deputy speaker
um can I warmly welcome the chancellor
to his place he more than anybody else
will be aware of the pressures that are
in the Health and Social care system as
we enter a difficult winter and would he
be able to give reassurance to the
people working in the NHS and to
patients across the country that he will
maintain levels of funding necessary to
cope with those winter pressures and
also cope with the challenges which the
Health and Social care system will face
in the future
well um I'm one of I think only two
chancellors who has been Health
secretary so I'm very very aware of the
pressures in the NHS and um
I'm not making any commitments
um but I would say that when it comes to
the NHS uh the whole country wants to
make sure that it's able to cope with
not just winter crises but also the
pressures that we've had since covert so
we will look at that very very carefully
but I would also like to see reform in
the way NHS funding is spent because I
think we can do better with the large
sums that we spend already
Bob Healey thank you madam Deputy
speaker after the government's
disastrous many budget I heard from the
constituent a single person first-time
buyer who had been saving to buy a home
for seven years and who can no longer
afford a mortgage
she described that as a kick in the
teeth
what does the chance of the executive
say to my constituent and to all those
old
people across the country
Contracting price Rises struggling with
increased mortgage costs and having
their pensions hit because of the
effects of three weeks of instability
caused by the economic incompetence of
the current prime minister and her
government
we've listened to our concerns we've
changed our policies as a result but
also In fairness the rise in interest
rates is not just because of actions
taken by the UK government in the last
few weeks it's because of global factors
and we will do everything we can going
forward to Shield people like your
constituent from those global factors
but we can't do everything
Dr Benson
there we are that's the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt confirming to MPS that he
has ditched almost all of the Prime
Minister Liz truss's tax cuts announcing
the mini budget three weeks ago one of
the most extraordinary
u-turns in recent political history for
labor Rachel Reeves said the government
had caused lasting damage policy u-turns
could not change they had set fire to
everything she said and are pretending
everything is now fine our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates is with me
here quite some climbed down this and
quite some moment in the Commons that's
right I mean I think today possibly was
the biggest set of u-turns since maybe
Dennis Healey went to the IMF maybe
since Sue is we are talking about an
entire Credo of a new government being
put in the dumpster and set on fire and
what Jeremy Hunt did across the last
what 90 minutes or so in the comments is
he made clear he was prepared to torch
almost every single bit of what Liz
truss has promised whether it's the tax
cuts that went out three weeks ago
whether it's the promise to protect
spending and defense whether it's the
promise never to do another windfall tax
on the energy companies whether it's to
maybe even come for parts of the triple
lock on pensions just an extraordinary
array of things that he is now promises
that have come out of Liz truss's lips
now uh in the bin because of this urgent
urgent need to reassure the markets I
think it became actually my I don't
think people may really realize this
became a lot more urgent this morning a
bit of the pension fund industry was
about to collapse and I think that
inside there they're very very nervous
about anything that looks like Britain
taking another risk so they're going out
of their way to make sure that this
government such as it is can actually
get on top of that question of borrowing
but if the morning was all about really
trying to restore some faith in Economic
Policy this afternoon has always been
all about political stability but there
I mean what a mess what an absolute mess
you had a question from the opposition
uh about the Prime Minister about the
fact that she made all of these promises
and they're all uh uh they're all the
subject of u-turns apparently by uh her
Chancellor she didn't turn up she wasn't
there we know where she was now and it's
quite ominous she was going to see
Graham Brady the chairman of the 1922
committee uh Graham Brady left the
Chamber of the House of Commons uh just
before four Liz truss entered the
buildings of the houses of Parliament
just before four uh and Liz truss
entered the House of Commons chamber
alongside Jeremy Hunt a little bit later
and appears in that Gap they went uh
they had what some are characterizing as
a long plan meeting I have to say this
morning they were saying that Liz trust
would be sitting along alongside Jeremy
Hunt when the statement was due to a
little bit earlier so I I will take that
one a little bit on advisory has been so
much else that Downing Street has said
in recent times but the bottom line is
that the two big unknowns right now what
Graham Brady said to Liz truss and then
later when the cabinet turned up and
we've seen a few of them Brandon Lewis
uh we've seen uh Michelle Donald when
the cabinet go in there what what what
do they say uh to Liz trust we just
don't know I mean I'm not picking up any
hints of cabinet dissent at the moment
but that's the group also that could
wield the knife so much unhappiness so
much lack of certainty about what to do
next amongst Tory MPS though there's no
Unity candidate there's no plan no
certainty it's got a miserable day to be
a Tory MP right and I want to pick up
with you what happens next in just a
moment but we're joined Now by John
Ashworth the shadow work and pensions uh
secretary so the mini budget has gone
but it is a little bit awkward for you
given that you backed a fair bit of it
well it was inevitable that the mini
budget would have to be reversed as we
were calling for it's obviously
personally humiliating for this trust
but